you could leader Nigel for eyeshadow
very good morning to you mr. France just
let's start because you know there's
this poster you are unveiled last week
of the EU being at breaking point with a
number of refugees and asylum seekers
that are coming into it a lot of
reaction to that I'm sure you're aware
this morning it's just here here's some
of it we contributed nothing relevant
nothing positive for I should withdraw
that poster it's it's nothing to do with
what's motivating 99.99% of people who
have voted leave or thinking of vote and
leave and he's he's trying to play on
fears it's highly inappropriate I didn't
like the poster I think you know in the
tone of the debate I would like to see
conducted over the next few days let me
just say that I didn't like the play so
I think that's the key point that even
people on the leave campaign are
uncomfortable with that poster it's
wrong it's the wrong poster it was the
wrong approach it's the wrong view
well when I saw that poster I shuddered
I I thought it was the wrong thing to do
the poster that Nigel Farage unveiled
last week was veil and racist and all
you're going to be speaking to him at
later on and I hope he does agree today
to withdraw that poster because that
kind of sentiment has no place in a
civilized debate Sena chief Rogers say
say with me well that's the deal Nicola
Sturgeon that violent racist withdraw it
let's have a look at this Marvin get it
sure I can reassure John man this was
the first of six posters for the last
week of the campaign and it was a set as
a one-day poster it was the only poster
that was actually talking about the
European Union itself that's why it said
on it the EU is failing us all and
actually if you live within the euro
zone you would say it's failing it and
if you see what Chancellor Merkel did
last summer by saying just come in
unlimited numbers so we do not want to
be at stay part of a union that is
failing in every room in the eurozone or
wherever likely to be members of a
political union and the problem we have
not being in the euro zone fine but
we're actually in a permanent minority
at the counts the ministers so so what
we were saying there was the the EU and
mrs. Merkel in particular has failed
very badly it's a complete statement of
fact in terms of the leave campaign it
has rather split you when Chris Grayling
two senior figures in it Chris Grayling
said it's plain wrong Michael Gove said
he shuddered when I saw Michael go
better look at his own posters pictures
of Abu Hamza warnings about terrorists
and and and and and and and murderers
coming into Britain at free will look
what has happened here is we have had a
tragic event in British politics and and
and and everybody they were over the
last couple of days
you know we've been trying to say all of
us say and do nothing over the last
couple of days that poster reflects the
truth of what's going on we have a new
poster coming out tomorrow morning and
will unveil a different poster for
everything with a house well that was a
one day poster that's the point I'm
making so that you can say yeah wish we
hadn't unveiled I wish my wish
an innocent member of parliament are not
being gunned down in the street okay
that's the point and I frankly and we
always I don't had that not happened I
don't think we would have had the kind
of rail that we've had I know we would
mr. France with respect because isn't
there an implication in that poster that
those people who
and large if we can judge from them we
understand that they were leaving
Croatia to head into Sylvania they are
would-be asylum secrets they up there
they're not economic migrants well I'm
sorry I don't agree with that at all
I've said from the start of this that
the European Union Janka got the policy
wrong Merkel compounded it the vast
majority of people who have come into
the Schengen zone would never qualify as
refugees under any trouble shame around
euro zone not the UK those people can
never come to the you well they can if
they get EU passports in years to couple
the points years to come many many why
don't they they get resolution isn't you
but you understand the rule shall we be
even if Germany allows them to have long
term residency they still cannot travel
to the UK the UK Ireland and Denmark
have an absolute veto until they get EU
passports there was no veto at all the
problem is we're losing sight what this
is really all about you tell me what
opted out of this we opted out of that
we are members of a political union the
majority of our laws now get made by
that Union their court in Luxembourg
overrules the British Parliament
overalls the British courts and we have
effectively no border controls to 500
million people and this referendum
in four days time is about one very
simple question do we wish to govern
ourselves or be part of that politically
Indian how nervous are you back to
Thursday it's a culmination of a life's
work I suppose for but a few years into
this yes over 20 I think I think people
out there that have made their minds up
that we should govern our own country we
should control our own borders we should
be in charge of our destiny I'm certain
they're going to go out and vote on
Thursday and we've been talking hasn't
probably bleating about Joe Cox you know
let's talk about it directly I mean
first of all the sadness the awfulness
of the event but you believe it's taken
the momentum out of the leave campaign
out of the whole campaigns what I said
you know there was a big momentum
developing right across the country a
tragic death a pause very difficult to
know or to see in the next three or four
days where either of the campaign's go
in terms of the public once again
connecting with it difficult to tell and
what do you think in a way I mean the
arguments have all been
ad infinitum and you know let's just
have the vote on Thursday it could be
that it makes little difference I don't
know I think it's very difficult to call
I do think one thing it's gonna be very
close on Thursday I think whatever
happens but what do you make of these
latest opinion polls but putting remain
back in the lead again well some say
some of the polling experts say that was
beginning to happen before the tragedy
others are less sure I don't think any
of us know the end of the day it's about
who goes down to vote on them but I
asked you about how worried you are
because so you watched I know with
interest the Scottish independence
referendum you saw that there was a
leave poll that put them ahead and then
yeah and then people began to think
really really hard do I really want to
do this do see a similar effect taking
place now that people I don't think they
want to me I don't yank aha I don't
because that in the end was based on the
economic argument that the SMPS argument
was based on oil and 113 dollars a
barrel
whereas this economic argument that
albeit it's a subset of who governs
Britain but this economic argument you
know when the Chancellor told us that
every household could be worse off by
thousands of pounds seventy percent of
the electorate did not believe it so I
don't think that us being told we'd be
worse off outside the European Union is
really having that bigger but the Prime
Minister's dress that today hasn't it's
about who's telling you and we've
discussed this before I know lis legions
of experts inside the United Kingdom
international experts and you know he
had likened it to a mechanic who knows
about cars well and looking at a car and
saying this is a defective car the
brakes and other things don't work and
you're still encouraging people to put
their children in it they can't all be
wrong can ban the defective car is the
one that's got the Euro is the one that
had the madness of Merkel's policy last
year is the one where euro skeptic
groups on the right center and left in
every country are springing up we've got
a chance to get off the train before it
hits the buffers it's going to be the
greatest opportunity of our lives to
take back our pride our self-respect our
independence and I hope again our place
in the world and I don't think I don't
think lining up a load of experts who
are using a completely full
economic model or being threatened by
the Chancellor actually works and also
the Prime Minister saying today there
are three basic lies at the heart of of
the leave campaign in this issue of the
amount of money that the UK gives to the
European Union they the 350 million
pounds well not true that Turkey is
somehow imminently about to join deeper
the European Union and that there's got
to be a European army right we pay
thirty four million pounds a day net net
to be an EU member that's maybe ten
billion pounds a year that is too much
on Turkey Mr Cameron has been the
biggest champion of Turkey joining the
European Union and on March the 18th he
was part of an accord of prime ministers
and presidents saying let's accelerate
the membership the French in the German
if they sing it well of course they're
saying it they're trying to help their
mate Dave because there's a referendum
four days away and as far as the
European arm is concerned they could not
be clearer they want a European army and
next week they're gonna start formal
discussions in terms of putting it
together let me ask you about what's a
Silberman the French ambassador to the
UK said to me about an hour ago talking
about the the border force officials the
UK border based on French soil there in
northern France in the pas de calais she
said well that could easily go so all
the people who are there waiting and
trying to get to the UK the French
aren't going to do much to stop them
well the relevant French ministers have
said nothing of a kind but we're going
to get more sorts of threats we're going
to be told in the next four days the
border will go in Calais and they went
trade with us we're gonna get all of
this actually the British being in
Calais doing passport checks are safe
France a very great deal of money and
it's that I think it's because otherwise
they would have to have done a job we're
doing it for them we've saved them a lot
of time and money over the course of the
last few years if at any point in the
future our border went back to Dover and
Folkston we would just police our border
and people without reason to come into
Britain would go back to France and give
them an even bigger headache okay well
let's get back to the next few days then
so this coast I think we have now we
have now got it again let's have a look
at it again
so we're not going to see this we're not
going to see this this poster of the
the refugees trying to get into I can
miss it ago but well I could see there
well breaking point we're not going to
see that again saying it's being
withdrawn it was a one-day poster I've
got six posters and you'll see the next
one tomorrow morning in the national
press and online and the next posters
are all about this country not the wider
point I was making there about the
European Union failing assault but that
but failing on immigration on
immigration failing terribly on
economics with the euro particularly
failing terribly okay but what is
Kamara's poster is it more about
migration to the UK doesn't mention it
now
tomorrow's poster is actually about the
center of this debate do we want to be
part of a political union let's not
pretend this is a trade bloc it's a
political union with full legal
authority or would we rather have our
own independent identity but do you
accept that that as it appears now you
you have lost that the economic argument
versus the migration our argument seems
to be winning out I think we need to be
very robust in the next four days
pointing out that actually Britain's
deal with the EU now is rotten
if 40 years ago there was a good reason
to get involved with something that gave
us tariff free access to the European
market that in a world of high tariffs
economically may have made sense now
Global tariffs have gone down and for
the benefit of that for the benefit of
that we pay a big fee we have to
regulate the 88% of our industry that is
not involved with European exports this
is a bad deal future for you maybe the
House of Lords I don't know what I'm
gonna do after Thursday I would just
like to win on Thursday okay see you
thank you very much indeed there you
keep leader there and that's all for the